[Music]
foreign
for Thursday March 30th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
a black box on a plane can explain what
happened if something goes wrong now a
similar Prospect is being taken on by
hospitals
new technology can help track what
happens in operating rooms helping
reduce medical errors and improve
patient safety joining me to discuss
this is Barbara sadik who wrote about
this for the Wall Street journals
Journal reports hey Barbara thanks for
joining me thanks for having me can you
start by telling us what is an or Black
Box an or black box is not a physical
black box but it's rather a system of
sensors and software
that records everything that's going on
in an operating room Barbara there's so
much that goes on in an operating room
how does this system capture what's
happening there it's artificial
intelligence it's used primarily to
improve performance and to improve
surgical outcomes how do they improve
surgical outcomes with this okay well
this is somewhat new it you know it's in
the last couple of years that this has
really been used more widely it allows
for people in the OR to work as a team
by seeing what might be going wrong over
time or
if something does go wrong they can see
why it went wrong or try to determine
how to do things better it can also
capture information that particular
hospitals want to know more about to see
how they're doing in that Realm
mentioned that this is fairly new where
is it being tested out now well it's in
24 hospitals in the United States Canada
and Western Europe
and each of the hospitals that has a
black spot has it only in a few
operating rooms not every operator room
okay so it's not everywhere yet but from
the hospitals that are testing it out
what have they found in using this so
for example at Duke University Medical
Center there are a couple of black boxes
and they've found that often specimens
that are taken from patients when they
are in the undergoing and operation
don't have a efficient system of getting
to the proper labs for analysis and so
they've been working on streamlining
that are there any concerns about using
this type of Technology the concerns
primarily have come from staff members
but the hospitals have spoken with the
staff and have explained that this is
not being used for punitive purposes
but rather to improve outcomes and
teamwork
what about patients do we know how they
feel about the use of this no because
I'm not sure how much they really know
that it's being used when a patient goes
in for surgery they sign a form a
consent form and in those ORS that are
using the black boxes that is included
in the consent form but I don't know
that anybody's told outright that
everything's being recorded
like the expert
experts kind of technology is the cure
of
juror of or
they certainly think that something like
this is the future yes because it
captures everything that one human being
can't or even a group of people can't
surgical safety Technologies
in Toronto the manufacturer of the black
boxes they think this is the wave of the
future there are other things going on
by other companies to supposedly improve
outcomes in operating rooms and so it's
too early to tell it remains to be seen
all right that's Barbara sadik who wrote
about this for wsj Journal reports
thanks for joining us Barbara thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing but a quick note on AI we are
still looking for your AI questions for
an upcoming episode do you want to know
more about chat GPT Microsoft's new Bing
or Google's new Bard do you want to know
how these AI programs work or how they
could change our lives email us a voice
recording with your AI question to tnb
wsj.com or leave a voicemail at
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
I'm Zoe Thomas from The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]